it's great to be joined today by Mayor
David narco its mayor of the city of
Northampton Massachusetts where the
david pakman show started no less and
also a city that is involved in the i
guess somewhat confusing directive from
the trump administration's executive
order with regard to so-called sanctuary
cities and mayor narco is to be more a
Healy the Attorney General here has been
very very direct since I think november
nine that she will do what is necessary
to protect people all people here in
Massachusetts what's your understanding
of as mayor what you can no longer do or
what you should be doing as a result of
this executive order is it clear oh
thank you David it's great to be on with
you so yeah so-called sanctuary cities
you know when you actually read what
president Trump's executive order said
it didn't actually didn't actually
effectuate any change when you read it
it actually he directs the Secretary of
Homeland Security and the Department of
Justice to study or review ways to cut
funding for sanctuary cities so it
didn't actually cut anything off and as
I've been saying for for many months me
first of all what what gets cities like
Northampton and other cities of
Massachusetts and across the country
this designation is we basically opted
not to enforce what the second security
itself has said is an optional order
which is an administrative detainer
request will accept you know a court
order will accept a warrant but we will
not hold people for up to 48 hours
without without charging them with
anything at the behest of a bureaucrat
in Washington and that's really what the
position of Northampton and many other
communities who have been called these
so-called sanctuary cities that's that's
really good position we've taken so I've
been I'm I am dubious that a city that
refuses to do something which in and of
itself it cannot be
required to do by the federal government
and this is on Fourth Amendment grounds
this is on Tenth Amendment grounds how
we could then be penalized so I'll be
watching very carefully like many other
mayors and attorneys general to see
exactly what this review that the
president's executive order has asked
for yields and much of this has to do
with individual decisions that police
departments make obviously in
consultation with City Council's mayor's
etc in terms of cooperation with ice
agents and and I think the key point is
the one you're getting at which is that
there is a range of ways in which police
departments can choose to cooperate with
ice agents and talk a little bit about
sort of how this relates to the
day-to-day of police because a lot of
this has to do with whether or not
immigration status is even looked into
during routine interactions with police
is that right that's correct and again
this gets back to the whole Tenth
Amendment question and and you know
whether or not the federal government
can essentially deputize local law
enforcement agency to carry out federal
programs you know our position is you
know we have enough other
responsibilities that we have to take
care of as a local municipality that we
are then going to begin doing the work
of federal agencies and you know what we
heard what I heard from members of our
immigrant community was that you know
these kinds of activities that are where
they're conducted by local law
enforcement really erodes trust and
local law enforcement that people begin
to fear even people that are that are
legal you know legally here with with
you know green cards etc that they begin
to fear even coming forward to the
police or reporting crimes to the police
it's something that even the
International Association of Chiefs of
Police has spoken about these about this
issue of eroding trust and so you know
when we when I know if david pacman is
driving through northampton it gets
pulled over your ramen attorneys I'm an
occurrence yes you
going to be treated like any other
citizen and the same thing with somebody
who you know maybe may look foreign or
maybe from another country we are not in
the business of asking people for their
papers you know like like Arizona tried
to do a few years ago and that law was
struck down I mean that this is the this
is the question is that you know it's
not the role of local police to fix the
nation's broken immigration system you
know I've been saying for years that
rather than come up with these you know
draconian measures to try to punish
cities and towns they should spend more
energy on trying to fix the immigration
system which creates this whole universe
of people that in many cases are
law-abiding they're paying taxes they
work here they have family that probably
have two children who are born here and
are US citizens and are trying to get
through the immigration system to mean
to become legal and hopefully become
citizens but they're they've sort of
been a victim of that of that process so
you know again the focus should be on
fixing the immigration system not on
somehow deputizing local police officers
to do the work of the federal government
I'm curious whether if there's been any
direction or communication with the
Massachusetts Attorney General Maura
Healey there's been a sort of
acknowledgement of the subjectivity of a
lot of what is sort of implicit here I
mean on the one hand there's no legal
definition for what is or is in a
sanctuary city we're talking about
different degrees as I mentioned of
cooperation with with immigration
enforcement agencies on the other hand
there's this when it comes to what the
federal government can or can't do in
these cases there's this 1987 case South
Dakota V dole which says that the
federal government can put requirements
on States when giving them funding but
that it cannot be unduly coercive which
again is a term that has no sort of
fixed objective definition is that part
of the complexity here it's part of the
complexity I know that there have been
interpretations of that particular case
to that says that say that you know
you know that some have argued that that
has to be that has to be part of the
original intent of the legislation that
it can't just be cobbled on after the
fact so there's been differing
interpretations and again this gets back
to the whole issue of whether or not the
president has the authority with the
stroke of a pen to basically modify a
series of laws that have been enacted by
Congress I mean title one which is you
know a program the Department of
Education that provides significant
federal education dollars to North
Hampton you know that was created under
a under a statute enacted by Congress so
there go and in many cases that the law
that protects people you know it's in
place to ensure that people have access
to an equal education so I think it's
going to get really complex when you
start to deny people federal funding you
know that in some ways is embedded in
our civil rights laws in terms of equal
access you know for kids with special
needs kids who are you know from
underserved populations whatever it is
that it's going to really get complex
that you're going that the Congress is
going to modify a law that's going to
take funding for these folks away in
some of the biggest metropolitan cities
in America yeah and you're sort of
repeating to the impact and there's
another angle to that as well and the
Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti made
this point which is you can as the
federal government clearly take away
funding from specific programs if a city
isn't adhering to the requirements of
that program but here what we're talking
about is the removal of funding because
there's not the the degree and scope of
cooperation between federal and local
officials which is a completely
different ballgame exactly exactly and
that's what I was referring to about the
interpretation of that other case that
that you know you can put conditions on
the education funding and you can
require you know local districts to
provide statistics and do reporting and
fill out forms which no believe me they
do and you can
what other you know kinds of
restrictions on how those funds are used
but but this is this goes pretty far
afield of imposing requirements on
educators for education funding have you
been briefed considered thought about or
is it anywhere in this entire discussion
what if anything could be repercussions
against individual individuals like
mayor's for example for not going along
with whatever is ultimately directed
after the so-called study takes place I
mean is that something you're thinking
about or the Attorney General has
discussed for example you know I've so
I've talked to the attorney general and
this is you know we're not really at
that level lighting at this point like
you know a lot of what they're looking
at are again these federal statutes the
underlying federal statutes for the for
the programs that cities and downs
received funding from you know during
the campaign you know bobby Jindal was
on the radio in Boston saying that you
know you know the mayor's of summer
villa Northampton etc should be put in
jail I mean there's a lot of rhetoric
but in terms of again I get back to
northampton's policy and our policy is
to exercise our option not to honor a
form which the form itself says
voluntary on the form these
administrative detainer requests which
you know the Department of Homeland
Security put out a legal memo citing
case law all around the country that
raised Fourth Amendment issues with
these particular detainer requests so
again there seems to be this perception
or at least the rhetoric is painting a
perception that you know the Northampton
police or other local municipalities are
going to be you know standing at the
borders and if a nice official or a
federal official comes into our city
we're going to somehow prevent them or
alternatively that we are allowing
people to act lawlessly or commit crimes
or do you know that and nothing could be
further from the truth I mean we
recently northampton was recently
involved in a major human
trafficking case that occurred that was
actually led by the Massachusetts
General we were one of the lead agencies
that involve people in this case these
were people that were undocumented in
some cases that were being you know
trafficked by unscrupulous people and we
were right in the thick of that
investigating it we help to break that
up so again we are not there seems to be
this perception that this is somehow a
you know get out of jail free card for
anybody who commits anyone as an
immigrant commits a crime and that is
just not the case what we want to do is
we want to stay away from programs that
ostensibly say that they're targeting
violent criminals but the vast majority
of the evidence shows that's not who
they're targeting and that's not who
they have targeted and that's not the
kind of community that we want to have
we want to have a community that feels
trusting of our Police Department and
who's willing to work with us to keep
community all communities safe within
within the city of Northampton and of
course the big picture of this and we
won't even get into it is the party of
so-called states rights coming in and
saying hey here's new stuff the federal
government will now tell states that
they have to do truly truly stunning
yeah i mean the leading the leading case
on this now is a 1987 case was with
authored by none other than Donald
Trump's favorite Supreme Court Justice
Scalia incident Julia you know who wrote
a who wrote an opinion which is sort of
a continuation at the line of cases from
the kid a New York case which it
basically says you know you can't but
you know you cannot this federal
government cannot deputize cannot
commandeer is the language that he used
of course he used it in the context of a
brady bill and and the federal
government requiring you know
municipalities to do federal work around
gun control but but it's the same
principles and that saves on the same
separation between you know we've got
the supremacy of the federal government
but anything not reserved to the federal
government is you know by definition is
the purview of state and local and their
and their subject
which means local government so yes it's
always amusing to me how you know the
party wants to get government out of our
affairs they want to you know they don't
want big government they want to give
power back to the states except when
they don't absolutely we've been
speaking with Mayor David narco it's of
Northampton Massachusetts we're going to
keep following what ultimately comes of
this and i know you will as well thanks
for talking to me about this thank you
David thanks for thanks for having me on
and and much success to you in this in
this show which as you said started
right here in the city of Mark Hampton
thank you